l'ambito in cui il lavoro per la mia
attività di ricerca è quello della
biorobotica la biorobotica ha
l'obiettivo di studiare da un punto di
vista ingegneristico il funzionamento
dei sistemi biologici con l'obiettivo
ultimo di sviluppare nuovi robot di tipo
b o ispirati cioè ispirati a sistemi
biologici che ha esistenti o allo
sviluppo di nuovi dispositivi biomedici
ed è all'interno di quest'area che
ricadono appunto le interfacce neurali
le interfacce orali non sono altro che
degli elettrodi
parte ne parliamo di interfacce neurali
invasive cioè che vengono inserite
all'interno del sistema nervoso per
poter mettere in comunicazione il
sistema nervoso a livello periferico o
centrale con un dispositivo artificiale
per capire meglio dove vengono collocate
dobbiamo sapere che il sistema nervoso e
alla base di
tutto ciò che riguarda il nostro no alle
nostre sensazioni e
movimenti tipo volontario o involontario
e sistema nervoso si divide
essenzialmente in due grandi
aree il sistema nervoso centrale
costituito dalla corteccia e dal midollo
spinale e testiamo nervoso periferico
costituito dai nervi periferici e
cranici
alla base del sistema nervoso quindi
alla base della trasmissione degli
impulsi nervosi c'è la cellula morale
quello che succede al momento in cui si
propaga l'impulso nervoso è che su
quella specie di salsicciotto che vedete
lì
si propaga una variazione del ponte
della differenza di potenziale tra
l'interno e l'esterno di questo che
viene chiamato assone quindi se siamo in
grado di posizionare la nostra
interfaccia neurale in prossimità di
questo ne siamo in grado di percepire
percepire l'impulso neurale
allora qui ho selezionato due principali
applicazioni
di inter per le interfacce neurali sono
ancora allo stato della ricerca
cioè quello che ho selezionato abbiamo
una per l'applicazione è a livello
centrale
in particolare per la corteccia visiva
per una paziente che si è aperta
volontaria per questo esperimento che
non ha neuro protesi visiva
micheli con stand e tecnologi dei capi
shanghai informano elevati
al side show
expo
sherlock holmes
file
next
si
no
all whites
io lascio smart lotus connections
è rigore
bruciando
il technology of print sharing
wow
tanto buono
by faber questo l'ater
in
nona
quindi quello che è successo che lei è
riuscita da credere sensazioni visive
certo questo è ben diverso da dire che
ha riconquistato la vista perduta però
la ricerca in questo senso sta
progredendo
l'altro tipo di applicazione riguarda
invece un'applicazione per che stiamo a
riposo periferico
all'interno di questo per questo su
questo esperimento hanno lavorato anche
la scuola superiore sant'anna per cui il
gruppo delle interfacce neurali della
scuola super santana per cui lavoro e
questo riguarda una neuro protesi per
una punta un ragazzo ha potato di arto
superiore
pierpaolo o un giovane italo brasiliano
accetta di fare da cavia il nome del
progresso la speranza è che gli
elettrodi inseriti nei nervi recisi del
braccio permettano di registrare le onde
cerebrali necessarie per azionare la
protesi
l'intervento consiste nell'inserire due
elettrodi nel nervo mediano e due in
quello ulnare
gli elettrodi usati sono più sottili di
un capello sono studiati per aderire al
nervo in modo da captare le onde
cerebrali e costituire un ponte tra
l'attività mentale lì per paolo e il
mondo artificiale del computer che dovrà
decodificarle e trasformarle in comandi
si tratta di una tecnica sperimentale
studiata per permettere punti di
contatto affidabili per le sei settimane
dell'esperimento al termine verranno
rimossi in attesa che i bioingegneri
sviluppino una nuova generazione di
elettrodi per impianti permanenti il
computer analizza il flusso caotico
dell'attività elettrica che arriva dal
cervello i programmi isolano i segnali
significativi e poco alla volta il
paziente impara a guidare l'interfaccia
meccanica ubbidiente la mano mette in
pratica i desideri di pierpaolo
eseguendo i movimenti desiderati
quindi questo è fatto vedere sono ancora
allo stato appunto della ricerca perché
molti limiti ancora ci sono su per
l'applicazione cronica di queste
interfacce quindi la nostra attività di
ricerca la mia e quella del gruppo delle
interfacce neurali della scuola
sant'anna è quello di superare alcuni di
questi limiti un approccio è quello di
creare un'interfaccia diciamo così
intelligente che sia in grado di
adattare il posizionamento delle
elettrodo all'interno del tessuto dopo
l'impianto in questo modo si può
assicurare un maggior tempo di vita e
maggior luce le qualità del segnale
dopo l'impianto un altro aspetto che
stiamo studiando è quello di ridurre
l'invasività quindi danno che andiamo a
fare nel nervo in seguito
all'inserimento del dell'interfaccia e
infine quello di
ricoprire la superficie dell'elettrodo
con un coating di tipo obiettivo che
aiuti a ridurre la reazione fibrotica
del tessuto attorno all'elettrodo in
qualche modo questi questi studi hanno
rivelato che c'è anche un potenziale
che possa
farci passare da quello che era un
progetto di ricerca ad un progetto
d'impresa
però quando mi sono trovato ad
affrontare questo tipo di
transizione mi sono trovata nella
situazione in cui si trovano molti
ricercatori italiani erano davanti un
muro che è il muro del
non sapere come affrontare le dinamiche
di un nuovo business impresa quindi sono
incappata in questo programma che è il
fullback best circa un programma di
scambi culturali promosso sia
dall'italia che dagli stati uniti che ha
proprio l'obiettivo di promuovere
l'imprenditoria italiana
mandando fisicamente ricercatori come me
nel campo dell'high tech
mandandoli
ovviamente un'idea imprenditoriale e
mandandole in silicon valley per un
periodo di formazione perché in silicon
valley perché la silicon valley che si
trova a sud di san francisco
concentra una serie di elementi
caratteristici prima di tutto è stata la
è qui che molte società importanti hanno
il loro quartier generale parliamo di
google di apple yahoo ebay sono tutte
concentrate in pochi km e oltre a questi
poi ci sono delle università di
prestigio come stanford berkeley o anche
il centro studi della nasa e in più a
completare il quadro c'è un folto gruppo
di investitori gli investitori che
decidono di investire il loro denaro
piuttosto che in titoli in borsa in
nuove idee di impresa quindi quello che
succede è che per imparare per avviare
una nuova società in silicon valley è
necessario cioè se prima nella silicon
valley c'è la ricerca alloro adesso c'è
la ricerca a loro agli imprenditori cioè
cercare di convincerli creando un piano
di un business plan quindi un piano di
business
convincente e soprattutto imparare a
comunicarlo ai possibili investitori
comunicarlo attraverso quello che viene
ormai definito ormai conosciuto come
elevator pitch cioè la possibilità di
convincere un imprenditore nell'arco di
tempo che intercorre
una corsa di un ascensore dal primo
all'ultimo piano di un grattacielo
quindi parte della mia attività della
mia formazione in silicon valley è stata
proprio quella di frequentare dei corsi
universitari
nella santa clara university
proprio sul presso la scuola di business
e poi vedere in pratica durante tre mesi
di stage in azienda locale come questi
principi vengono poi appunto messi in
pratica in pratica da una start up del
posto il tutto ovviamente messo insieme
è amalgamato da una
un'importante rete di networking che è
necessario fare nel momento in cui sei
lì per poter cercare di trovare
personaggi
con un'esperienza pregressa
impresa che possano darti consigli utili
e importanti per rendere la tua idea
effettiva
in aggiunta quindi a questo poi
ovviamente momento in cui siamo in
questo in questo tipo di mondo
uno degli eventi e così partecipe
proprio quello di dei birthers
divertenti competition ossia tutti
questi aspiranti imprenditori si sfidano
a colpi di business plan
tutte queste questi elementi hanno sono
stati poi convogliate all'interno
del mio progetto
imprenditoriale dando così vita a quello
che ho chiamato smania dove smania sta
per smart neural interface and advanced
modeling
importante è stato l'aiuto di
aver conosciuto personaggi
totalmente diversi da quelle che
incontriamo qui in italia un esempio per
esempio è proprio questo di josh
makeover che è un imprenditore seria
seriale tipico genitore della silicon
valley
oltre ad avere una formazione di
altissimo livello nba alla columbia
university
ha studiato al mit poi al new york
university eccetera eccetera ha
fondato
in sette o otto
imprese nel campo della biomedica
dico da un imprenditore modello della
silicon valley perché non solo le
affondate ma è arrivato in punta ad un
punto in cui ha fatto quella che si
chiama exit strategy di successo cioè
riuscito a vendere per svariati milioni
di centinaia di milioni di dollari
molte di queste sue società che ha
fondato in pochissimi anni poi
ovviamente molto importante è conoscere
anche altri giovani imprenditori che
sono nella tua stessa barca come ad
esempio lisabetta bianchini con cui
abbiamo cominciato un nuovo progetto
insieme
proprio per capire e mettere insieme
appunto le tue idee di business quindi
quello che mi aspetta ora è ovviamente
mettere in pratica tutto quello che ho
imparato durante gli anni di ricerca e
durante i miei anni di formazione in
silicon valley per dare vita a questo a
questo progetto e renderlo quindi una
realtà ovviamente senza dimenticare le
lezioni importanti
imparati imparate proprio lì
una tra queste che mi ha colpito tra
tutte è quella che nel momento in cui
vogliamo davvero creare qualcosa di
importante e di grande è importante
selezionare e circondarsi di persone in
gamba di persone brave volendo anche più
bravi di te quindi non aver paura del
talento ed evitare di cercare
di circondarsi di persone meno brave di
che quindi
ricordati che io
prendo noi a collaborare con consensuale
chiostri talenti mentre i b prendono i c
e così le c è così e così via
quindi ringrazio voi per l'attenzione e
tutto il gruppo delle interfacce neurali
della scuola sant'anna